>>> THE STATE OF WASHINGTON HAS
ENACTED A DOZEN POLICE REFORM
LAWS FOLLOWING NEARLY A YEAR OF
NATIONWIDE PROTESTS OVER POLICE
BRUTALITY.
ACCORDING TO A SOCIAL JUSTICE
GROUP, MORE THAN $840 MILLION
WERE CUT FROM U.S. POLICE
BUDGETS, THAT WAS IN 2020.
THE SEATTLE PD IS STRUGGLING
UNDER THE PUBLIC BACKLASH.
THE POLICE CHIEF THERE TELLS CBS
NEWS THAT 260 OFFICERS, THAT'S
ABOUT 20% OF THE FORCE, HAVE
LEFT IN THE PAST YEAR AND A
HALF.
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A SECOND.
CARTER EVANS SPOKE TO ONE
OFFICER WHO SAYS THE CITY DOES
NOT HAVE THEIR BACKS.
>> Reporter: WHAT'S THE BIGGEST
COMPLAINT AMONG OFFICERS?
>> LEADERSHIP.
>> Reporter: OFFICER CLAYTON
POWELL HAS SERVED 27 YEARS ON
THE STREETS OF SEATTLE.
>> 30 YEARS WAS MY GOAL.
>> Reporter: THREE YEARS SHORT.
WHY ARE YOU RETIRING NOW?
>> THE SUPPORT WE HAD IN MY
GENERATION OF POLICING IS FLOW
LONGER THERE.
>> Reporter: LAST SUMMER'S
PROTESTS OVER THE KILLING OF
GEORGE FLOYD LED TO VIOLENT
CLASHES WITH SEATTLE POLICE.
POWELL SAYS THE STRESS ON
OFFICERS WAS COMPOUNDED BY CITY
LEADERS' DECISIONS TO ABANDON A
POLICE PRECINCT AND LETTING
DEMONSTRATORS, SOME ARMED,
OCCUPY AN ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD
FOR A FULL MONTH.
>> WHEN YOU'RE GOT ROCKS AND
BOTTLES IN SOME CASES, CINDER
BLOCKS THROWN AT YOU AND WE HAVE
TO TAKE IT, IT'S DISCOURAGING.
>> Reporter: WERE YOU TOLD NOT
TO REACT?
>> IN MOST CASES, YEAH.
WHEN YOU SEE BUSINESSES GET
DESTROYED AND FAMILIES LOSE
THEIR LIVELIHOOD BECAUSE OF THAT
DESTRUCTION, AND WE CAN'T DO
ANYTHING ABOUT IT, WE'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO INTERCEDE.
>> Reporter: YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED
TO INTERCEDE?
>> NO, NO.
[ CHANTS ]
>> Reporter: CITY LEADERS
ALLOWED THE POLICE-FREE ZONE
AFTER PROTESTES WERE REPEATEDLY
HIT BY TEARGAS BUT CLOSED IT
DOWN AFTER WEEKS OF VIOLENCE.
>> THE REAL ISSUE HERE IS THAT
FOR GENERATIONS OUR BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITY MEMBERS HAVE
BEEN ASKING FOR MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> Reporter: CITY COUNCIL WOMAN
TAMMY MORALES VOTED FOR A 13%
CUT IN THE POLICE BUDGET IN
NOVEMBER.
>> WE SPEND ABOUT $400 MILLION A
YEAR ON THE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AS A CITY, WE DON'T SPEND ON THE
KIND OF THINGS THAT COULD REALLY
SUPPORT NEIGHBORHOODS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING, NEIGHBORHOOD
PLANNING, SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT.
>> Reporter: YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT TAKING THAT MONEY AND
APPROACHING A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM
AT THE GROUND LEVEL NOW.
>> YEAH.
>> WE'RE HERE TO FIX A BROKEN
SYSTEM!
>> Reporter: THE MONEY THE
COUNCIL CUT FROM POLICE WILL BE
REALLOCATED THROUGH A
STILL-UNDEFINED PROCESS
INVOLVING COMMUNITIES MEMBERS.
IN THE MEANTIME, IS THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT UNDERFUNDED TO DO ITS
JOB WHILE YOU'RE DEVELOPING ALL
THESE OTHER RESOURCES?
>> I WOULD SAY NO.
>> Reporter: IF THE CRIME RATE
GOES UP, IS THAT ACCEPTABLE?
>> SO IF WE'RE INVESTING IN
COMMUNITIES THE WAY WE SHOULD
BE, WE CAN BEGIN TO ADDRESS
THAT.
>> I INFORMED THE MAYOR OF MY
INTENT TO RETIRE FROM THE
SEATTLE POLICE DEPARTMENT --
>> Reporter: AFTER THE COUNCIL
CUT THE POLICE BUDGET, THE
DEPARTMENT'S THEN-CHIEF, CARMEN
BEST, RETIRED EARLY IN PROTEST.
INTERIM CHIEF ADRIAN DIAZ TOOK
OVER.
DOES IT CONCERN YOU THAT SO MANY
PEOPLE ARE LEAVING THE
DEPARTMENT SO FAST?
>> YOU KNOW IT DOES BECAUSE WE
SAW OUR SHOOTINGS GO UP, WE SAW
OUR HOMICIDES GO UP.
>> Reporter: DOES THIS SLOW DOWN
RESPONSE TIME?
>> IT SSLOWS DOWN RESPONSE TIME.
>> Reporter: YOU'RE FORCED TO
CUT THE VERY PEOPLE THAT
PROTESTERS WOULD LIKE TO SEE
MORE OF ON YOUR FORCE.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, I THINK THOSE ARE SO
VALUABLE.
>> Reporter: WHILE CLAYTON
POWELL OBJECTS TO HOW THE CITY
IS TREATING ITS POLICE FORCE, AS
AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN MAN HE SAYS
HE UNDERSTANDS THE OUTRAGE OVER
THE MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD AND
OTHERS.
>> THAT COULD BE ME.
THAT COULD BE MY SON.
THAT COULD BE A RELATIVE.
THAT COULD BE A FRIEND.
THERE NEEDS TO BE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW THINGS GOT
TO BE THE WAY THEY ARE.
>> Reporter: BUT DEFUNDING THE
POLICE, IS THAT THE WAY TO DO
IT?
>> NO.
IF ANYTHING YOU NEED MORE
FUNDING.
>> Reporter: THAT'S UNLIKELY.
ANOTHER $5 MILLION IN POLICE
BUDGET CUTS ARE STILL ON THE
TABLE.
FOR "CBS THIS MORNING," CARTER
EVANS, SEATTLE.
>> THAT'S A VERY DIFFICULT
SITUATION.
I UNDERSTAND THE OUTRAGE, BUT I
ALSO UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE TO HAVE
A POLICE DEPARTMENT.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU HAVE TO HAVE A WORKING
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
>> THE PROBLEM IS YOU WANT TO
SUSTAIN THE POLICE DEPARTMENT
WHILE YOU ALSO ADDRESS THESE
OTHER ISSUES IN COMMUNITIES AND
SUPPORTING THOSE COMMUNITIES.
YOU WANT TO DO BOTH, WHICH